どうやって起きてますか目覚まし時計お母さん彼ピッピ彼女っちゃんパパジージャパ
バーチャまあいろんなを起業さがあるんですけどもうなんかもっとこう
びっくりして起きたら一番すっきりと受けられるんじゃねーかということで僕も
ちょっとまあいろいろ試してみたんですけども今回新しいものを見つけました
こちらなぜこういう類のやつ使ったことがよくわからないんです
けどすっごい濃いんですよグレネード弾です
グレネードだっていいのかな俺もよくわかんないけど使い方が患ったんですよ本体+し
てるずう2個新品サバゲーとかでよくあれあのね仙蔵とかで行
ドンッ
トップ
バーン
みたいなやつでそれを朝なければすぎ起きるんだねっていうのが髑髏バッグだよね公園
フリン君の言って使うんだよかっこいい音ずれずこれこれこれの使うらしいですよね
これイイ女使いたくないんですけど
まず本当にこうずーっっと高圧が2つクロスからね誰か起こす前に1回パクトやっぱで
やりますパパ
魔王スパイダーウィッショップセフティピーン
うん
[音楽]
ブービークリーナー関数ですや正直マジびびったよアーゲームとか映画でしか見たこと
ないんだ
実際にグレネードを投げるっていうの初めてですできます
[音楽]
はっはっはっはっ
[拍手]
うんうんっ
うほほーヨッパマって言わ耳が消えてなるこれやべーぞアホの威力ですよやっぱ
[音楽]
仏で今からターゲットがもう寝ると思うんですけどもう何したターゲットまた早い
みたいなのでせっかくなのでちょびっとほとんど大きなが目覚ましい起こしてあげよう
と思いますではおやすみ
ん
分
お盆
うんうん
うん
ん
[音楽]
うん
んん
ん
えっ
[音楽]
ん
ブーブー
dare
me
teame
ええええええ
ana あああっ
wh
普通
あー夫がてが過ぎてヤバイと思ったら
この中でも等
圧縮します4日
はっはっはん
me
goo